الساعات الماضيه المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الروسيه ماريه زخرفه نزلت توجيهي اهانات
للاوروبيين والامريكيين
مو يعني انه قصف الجبهات غريب عليها اصلا
او الشاي بس دوز الاهانات الساعات الماضيه
صراحه كان مكثف والمنصه كالعاده حسبها على
تيليجرام اخر اللي ضربت فيهم هم
الاوروبيين اللي سوت برلمانهم الاربعاء
على قرار يصرف روسيا بدوله رائعيه للارهاب
بسبب الحرب على اوكرانيا
انا
[تصفيق]
قرار وحركه زي هذه اكيد ما راح تفوتها
زخرفه اللي كتبت على قناتها على التلجرام
مثل ما البرلمان الاوروبي صرنا في روسيا
راعيه للارهاب فانا بقترح تصنيف البرلمان
الاوروبي راعي للحماقه
يعني
امس انتشرت اخبار انه خلاص منظمه الصحه
العالميه بتعتزم تغيير اسم الجدري القرود
من منقي بوكس الى خبر مصدره من الصدق
الامريكيين نقلا عن مصادر مطلعه قالت انه
خلاص الصحه العالميه هتغير الاسم لازاله
وصمه العار المرتبطه بالاسم منظمه الصحه
كانت من كم شهر قالت انها بتفكر تغير
الاسم عشان الموضوع وصمه العالم لكن حسب
اللي صاير الان انه في ضغوط اضافيه سببها
البيت الابيض اللي يقول لهم يتغير الاسم
عالميين هي راح نغيره احنا داخلين مع
نفسنا ما نعتمدكم الوصمه اللي تكلم فيها
الامريكان وغيرهم بيقصدوا فيها انه مسمى
جدري القرود في تمييز على اساس اللون
وتلميح لاصل الفيروس اللي نشا في افريقيا
وصلت العار هذه مخليه كثير ناس يرفضوا حتى
التطعيم بحسب البيت الابيض وعلى فكره ترى
هذه مو اول مره بتغيير اسم فيروس بسبب
موضوع وصمت العار او هذا النوع من الجلد
هذا النوع من الجدل صار قبل كده واحد تنمو
بالفتره بعيده لو تذكره مشاهدينا اكيد ما
حنقدر ننسى يعني ما لحقنا ننسى اصلا فيلم
الفيروس الصيني او كرونه وكل الجدل اللي
صار عليه طيب زي ما سمعته الخبر ما في
سيره روسيا باي شكل ما لهم دخل يعني
الجماعه رغم كده خروف استغلته وحذفت لها
اهانه على الامريكيين وبرده على تلجرام
كتبت انه كجزء من مكافحه وسمه العار منظمه
الصحه العالميه راح تغير تسميه الجدري
القرود الى بوكس وقالت هل ترى هذه المره
ايش القصه حقوق القرده هي اللي منتهكه ولا
المسؤولين الامريكيين شعروا بالانتهاك
لانه شايفين انه الموضوع بيمسهم
قصدي طبعا
[موسيقى]